[Music]
perpetual
still can't believe they're all here and
all well
in march she was rushed to hospital with
covid
she ended up on a ventilator in an
induced coma
and her babies were born by cesarean
section
she thought they hadn't made it
i was pregnant at 24 5 weeks at that
stage
by the time i woke up i was so
disoriented because
i couldn't i lost my pregnancy
so i couldn't see my bump anymore i was
really really worried and disoriented
the babies pascal and palmer were so
premature they were placed in incubators
on the special care unit
their mum spent another 16 days on
critical care
before eventually meeting them
they were so tiny
they didn't look anywhere like my
previous two other kids
so i couldn't touch them i couldn't
the nurse had to get my hand to touch
them
and i felt so emotional what was your
reaction
when you found out um that perpetual had
pulled through but
but also that the twins had survived as
well
so i'm happy the dreams were there
they've been delivered
but the thing is is my wife coming home
at that point it was not clear to me go
but she did come home they all did
much to their older brother and sister's
delight
sometime when i look at them i
get them in tears because
i never knew they would make it
and you know it's amazing
perpetual herself a hospital consultant
says she and the twins are now well
and their laughter is just the tonic
after the months of worry
they've all been through
lisa dowd sky news birmingham